here with more Missouri Senator Josh
Hawley is with a center to tell us about
this bill
well listen Tony you've laid it out
perfectly which is that when people sin
with a vote or send members of Congress
to Washington they expect them to do the
people's business not to be day trading
on the stock market not to be using the
information that they get from briefings
to go and make a quick Buck on Wall
Street so here's what my bill does it
says no more trading of Stocks by
members of Congress in fact no more
ownership of stocks but members of
Congress if you want to save fine put it
in a mutual fund like most Americans do
but Nancy Pelosi is the perfect example
of what should not be happening in D.C
which is people getting rich off in the
stock market off of information they
know because they're a member of
Congress and pelosiwa traded between 1
million and 5 million in stocks for
semiconductors only days before Congress
allocated 52 million to the industry am
I right on that senator
that's the report Sean and there's lots
of reports like that with her with her
family and other members of Congress I
mean this is a problem that has been
going on for years and she is just a
perfect example of how rich people can
get by using their information listen
insider trading is already illegal and
we're talking here about members of
Congress the briefings that they get the
information that we have from hearings
it's it's information that most
Americans don't have because of course
that's why they send us to Congress is
to do their business not to turn that
around and to get rich off of it that's
why I call it the Pelosi act we need to
act right now you know I I don't like
the idea of term limits because I would
like to think we're a free Society but I
think over time it's a bad idea probably
whose time has come because people get
entrenched in the swamp over time and if
people just go serve and go home I think
they'd be more inclined to do the
people's business one of the issues that
comes up whenever we talk about this is
you know whether or not you want to put
money in a blind trust I'm not sure if I
even trust that because somebody that
they know is running the blind trust and
they could whisper in the ear of that
person oh you may want to invest in
semiconductor stuff that to me would
probably go on more often than we knew
you know Shannon this is one of the
reasons why I personally my wife and I
we've got all of our savings in mutual
funds for that reason broad-based mutual
funds we don't have a trust and the bill
I've introduced is the toughest bill on
ethics on stock trading ethics that is
out there but I tell you what if we can
get a bill through the congress with no
blind trust I'm for it 100 I don't use
them I don't think other members of
Congress should and I'd be happy to ban
them all right Senator great bill I hope
it passes thank you for being with us
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else